this is how you make Japanese katsu
curry if you're trying to impress
somebody make this dish it's so good to
make the Japanese Curry add your oil and
add our onion
your garlic ginger pinch of salt
I have paprika for color a bit more oil
the Japanese curry powder this is the
curry powder I use toast this for a few
minutes butter and our flour we are now
making a roux toast the flour for a few
minutes then add your grated apples and
your water I'm gonna add a chicken stock
Cube we're gonna transfer it to a
blender blend until nice and smooth back
to the pot
carrots and your potatoes we're gonna
let this simmer until the potatoes are
pork tender finish it with soy sauce
Worcestershire sauce and honey now for
the tonkatsu kosher salts and black
pepper
egg water and flour
then into the batter then into our panko
fry the pork
foreign